I was like for real I'm the only one
that's ever been here for you what the
heck like don't turn on me like don't
backstab you know someone who's always
had your back Paul do you promise to
love Micah supporting her through the
experiences of your lives and to share
in the joys of choosing one another
for as long as your souls are united
I love you
but
but I don't think that we can choose
each other right now
um
but I think that we're not there
were you surprised by his decision at
the altar it's hard to say I think that
you know I'm not sure how it comes off
in the show I haven't seen it but I was
so emotional that entire day
um I think deep down I knew that he
wasn't gonna say yes and it hurt it hurt
really bad it felt like I was walking up
to the death of a relationship and I
think that's why I was so emotional and
at the altar I wanted to give him that
one last chance to like prove me wrong
like no you're gonna take the leap
you're gonna you're gonna try you're
gonna show me you're willing to risk it
all yeah and he wasn't so if he had said
yes would you have said yes
I've said yes in that moment I was
willing to risk it
I know what the
absolutely no
but I was willing to try In This Moment
the best thing that I can do for us is
give you the opportunity to answer first
I mean I'm sure you've thought about
this in the week since but if you had
gone first and you had said yes do you
think that he would have said yes you
think that that would have signaled the
all in on your part that he maybe
thought that he was missing yeah so it's
actually quite the contrary I wasn't I
would say yes
he's afraid of I'm not afraid of looking
stupid I already looked
um quite frankly so it's like I wanted
him to say yes for him I wanted him to
say yes because it's what he wanted I
didn't want him to feel pressured
because he just saw someone he loves
like being so vulnerable and say yes and
I wanted him to you know have to you
know
decide talk to me about your
relationship with Paul I I it seemed
like when we're watching the pods
it seemed like maybe a little mismatched
but then again you can like see it you
can you and you can see why yeah I think
that that's one of the things about Paul
and I the action of working I think
we're really different
um I think he kind of levels me out a
little bit I think I can be kind of like
all over the place like woo-woo and he's
like all right well this is the Baseline
of what reality is so come meet me a
little bit closer you know one thing I
was scared about was like I don't want
him to do my Sparkle and I don't want to
like pretty much just stress him out
um and maybe that's why I didn't work
out I'm not sure
um but in in a way he was the perfect
person for me he was the only person for
me
um on this show and I would not have
changed anything about choosing him
you're not into it
I just feel like that this one's that I
met for for you Micah I mean I feel like
Shelby was a scene stealer it felt great
to watch you sort of stand out for Paul
in that moment when she was like this is
not it and you're like no this is my guy
like you need to get on board were you
at any point like yo you're up you're
gonna be on TV Shelby dial it down a
notch yeah I was like can you chill I
was like we can talk about this later
like but you know she is so true to who
she is she's a strong woman she she
sticks out for the people she loves and
she loves me so she does not want
anything bad for me she wants me to be
happy and she's gonna ride for me and in
that moment she didn't feel like it was
right she was gonna say something yeah
yeah she most definitely did
yeah during the wedding she's like this
is what I wanted that's how I wanted it
to go one of my bridesmaids said she was
squeezing her hand like what is this
girl about to do she didn't even know
will you have this woman
from this day forward to be your wedded
wife
in times of celebration in times of
sadness
if so say I will
Tiffany I most definitely will
[Music]
Tiffany what was that day like for you I
mean was there any doubt in your mind it
felt like you guys had argued about like
money and bills which like spoiler alert
that's what all married people fight
over
no that says we're married like fighting
about bills yeah there was no doubt in
my mind it sounds crazy but I just knew
it it was just a gut feeling that Brett
was it Brett was my person so I had no
doubt I don't know how it looks on this
show but I think I was so emotional
um I I think as I'm getting dressed
because I was like this is it like I've
dated for so long I've dated so many
people and I'm finally here at this
moment so ah why am I getting emotional
just thinking about it
um but yeah no doubts it seemed like you
and Brett I I mean I don't want to say
it was like Smooth Sailing because I'm
sure there were Rocky patches and
obviously it's very emotional but what
was it about Brett that you were like
yeah this is the I think this is the guy
I think this is the real deal
yeah I
I like past Behavior digging into who
they actually are so that way I know how
they're going to treat me in the future
and I think what Brett I I thought I
needed somebody that was like super
outgoing very like Lively and vibrant
Brett's not that kind of guy Brad is
like the type of person where
um he is a little bit more introverted
but man he is just a beautiful person a
beautiful soul inside and out
um so I was able to see that during the
pause and like really just asking those
questions I'm thankful that the pods
like gave me that experience to ask
those hard questions to really get to
know him we kind of talk about like if
if we were to meet in the real world
what we have taken the time to really uh
take it take a chance of one another but
we have asked those hard questions but
the pods allow me to do that
[Music]
in the moment I pick up the phone I just
hear him crying just like just crying
um and he's like he's gone he's gone I'm
like what are you talking about he's
like he's gone he's gone he's gone
my oldest brother is gone
it seemed like one of the things holding
Brett back was like
just his fear of like a fear of like
good things happening in general to him
because of his past history I guess it
may have to leave that for Brett to
answer my thing was I wanted to provide
him reassurance that it wasn't going
anywhere and that I'm a good
like I'm not here to hurt him I didn't
have any type of motives for being on
the show simply to find my person so
um I think during the pots it was just
constantly providing him that
reassurance and and see if he came
around and if he didn't that was fine I
just knew I wanted to have him in my
life for both of you ladies were you
able to suss out who was on the show I'm
sure at this point we're Four Seasons in
there's people who want to be on the
show to like build a career and then
show to find love will be able to suss
that out whether it's the other women or
or even on the or in the guys yeah I
guess you just never know you know I I
like to give people the benefit of Adele
I mean people are just you know they're
gonna always do what they want to do
um I just had to stay true to who I was
yeah like how about for you yeah I mean
you know people are pulling theatrics
are doing whatever to try to try to like
get some sort of clout or something I
think the most important thing was to
kind of stay in my lane and just focus
on my relationship
foreign